[Music]
big budgets used to be exclusive to
major hollywood films but that was
before the current golden age of
television started in the late 1990s tv
has never been this good or this pricey
here are some of the most expensive
scenes ever shot for the small screen at
217 million dollars the pacific was the
most expensive mini-series ever made
when it was released in 2010. its
depiction of the palelu beach landings
in world war ii alone cost five million
dollars a figure that becomes even more
staggering when you read the hollywood
reporter's invoice breakdown some 300
actors worked on the four-day shoot the
leads daily rate was 700
stunned extras 150 and regular extras 70
this was economical according to the
producers who avoided big stars to
offset the show's real money burners
which included uniforms visual effects
and a whole arsenal of guns explosives
and tanks then there was a cgi even
simple effects such as adding a muzzle
flash to a gunshot cost about seven
hundred dollars more complicated
adjustments such as removing or masking
features in the image run about forty
thousand dollars per shot three and a
half seconds of a landing craft for
example cost almost thirty thousand
dollars and these are just the
post-production expenses each standard
take drawing principal photography costs
thirteen thousand five hundred dollars
the wide shots of which there were four
per day could add up to seventy thousand
dollars
costs money that's why the pilot episode
for last which famously depicts a plane
crash cost abc between 10 million and 14
million dollars the most expensive pilot
in history at the time the scene was
constructed in multiple locations it
began aboard a mugged up plane interior
in a california soundstage where
director jj abrams used a skillful blend
of practical ingenuity and cgi to
capture the horrifying panic as the
aircraft drops out of the sky the cgi
takes over as we see the plane break
apart and scatter across the ocean some
additional disturbing moments were
filmed on the coast of oahu hawaii it
was here that the most expensive prop
was used a decommissioned airliner the
passenger plane was bought in the mojave
desert and then transports it to hawaii
where it was staged in catastrophic
fashion fortunately abc's investment
would reap major dividends lost became
one of the biggest shows of the 2000s
and occasionally one of its most
confusing
all right dude we're from the future
game of thrones is a big show a very big
show everything about it is massive
including the budget metro reports that
the notorious eighth season costs 90
million dollars which means 15 million
dollars for each of the season's six
episodes of these it's likely that the
battle of winterfell costs the most all
of the pricey ingredients are here a
sweeping cast with established fame and
hefty salaries scores of extras decked
in unique costumes towering set design
and seamless integration of cgi however
this huge battle split opinion among
viewers many bemoaned how dimly lit the
cinematography was complaining that they
had to adjust the brightness on their
tvs because it was simply too dark to
watch
i can't see that's your problem not mine
other viewers loved it with a headline
at games radar quoting a claim that it
was the most intense episode in
television history
the 18 million dollar pilot of boardwalk
empire is effectively one big piece of
world building that displays the show's
glitz and glamour including the lavish
boardwalk set that cost five million
dollars
that's a lot it's quite a lot the
boardwalk set was staged in greenpoint
brooklyn and took months to build in an
interview with the chicago tribune set
designer bob shaw said that it was the
biggest outdoor set built in new york
city in almost 100 years then there were
the small details the storefronts were
based closely on the atlantic city
boardwalk circa 1920. that's just one
part of the exhaustive research that
went into the project which covered
everything from key moments of world war
one and prohibition to the wider popular
culture of the era
budgets tend to bulge when warfare and
especially fire-breathing dragons are
involved
the crown has neither of those things
but 70 years of real history doesn't
come cheap in fact the crown is one of
the most expensive shows ever made with
the first season costing 130 million
dollars the priciest scene in the 10
episode run is queen elizabeth ii's
wedding it features a replica dress that
according to harper's bazaar costs 37
000 to make this standout piece of
wardrobe was just one part of the show's
ornate grandeur in a conversation on the
red carpet actor claire foy said every
single penny was spent on screen all the
locations are appropriate but
extraordinary the costumes were handmade
and designed also we were shooting in
london it's so rare that you're able to
shoot in london we shut down the mall
for an entire morning matt smith who
played prince philip added we had great
costumes great locations so i think all
the money went on screen
sensate was always going to be an
expensive show because its 8 main
characters are from every corner of the
earth according to wired this
globetrotting extravaganza was costing
netflix nine million dollars per episode
when it was cancelled in june 2017. of
the show's 24 episodes season two's
christmas special was likely the most
expensive in particular an underwater
scene that took the cast and crew all
the way to malta filming underwater is
far more complex than filming on dry
land and it often requires up to three
times as many crew members then there
are creative concerns namely the
complications affecting light and color
which means waiting for the opportune
time period on the open sea or using
elaborate lighting equipment if working
in a tank either way it's a matter of
crew time and technology all of which
cost plenty of money jack ryan is one of
amazon's proudest exhibits it's
announced the company's intention to
spend big money on big drama 8 million
dollars per episode to be exact every
action scene is an explosive testament
to amazon's deep pockets pinpointing a
certain scene isn't easy because there
are so many to choose from but the
subway shootout in season 1 episode 8 is
definitely a highlight as with so much
of contemporary tv the lines between
reality and cg are blurred as jack ryan
edges down the subway tunnel gun in hand
after a brief shootout a train barrels
along the tracks obliterating one of the
men ryan's just shot and it's exactly
that type of cgi-driven moment that can
take a big bite out of an episode's
budget and it was totally worth it most
fans like to see their protagonists kick
ass especially when they're dealing with
zombies depicting this is usually a
rather modest affair at least in the
scheme of mega budget tv but which
walking dead scene took the biggest
chunk out of the show's budget well
season seven's ninth episode saw prices
go up when it featured two old cars a
line of wire and a whole lot of walkers
the bulk of the cast was likely incurred
during post-production processing all of
those cgi flying limbs does not come
cheap even the walkers moans and groans
were added by audio specialists the
undead extras are asked to remain silent
as usual this scene was an amplification
of a budget that was already full of
expensive details for example yahoo
reports that amc paid the families of
sanoya georgia where the majority of the
series has filmed 400 a month to
compensate for the hassle of production
and to discourage locals from sharing
any spoilers they might have seen
when friends started in 1994 the budget
was so tight that producers had to use
the bottle episode format which required
the crew to use as few sets as possible
and not even think of having special
guests well as everyone on the face of
the earth knows friends will become one
of the biggest shows in the history of
american television earning warner
brothers a yearly syndication revenue of
one billion dollars this success saw the
modestly staged show end up costing a
pretty penny for nbc by the eighth
season each main cast member was earning
750 000
for every 30 minutes episode that's 25
000 a minute so when brad pitt turned up
for thanksgiving dinner it couldn't have
been cheap still it's a no-brainer when
the choice is between money and an
unforgettable episode what's more
important your friends or money
just like with lost back in 2004
showrunner jj abrams wanted fringe to
make a strong first impression
unfortunately for fox executives a
sequence that included scores of extras
face melting special effects and a
custom built set would contribute to a
10 million budget the cost breakdown
would have shared much in common with
last a mugged up plane interior a sound
stage and detailed cgi only this time
there was a strong serving of gory
makeup applied to about a dozen extras
aboard the doomed plane fringe like
other entries on this list would see the
budget fall after its pilot plateauing
at a rate of 4 million per episode
yet another case of pilot extravagance
the costumes period sets and star power
of vinyl is said to have cost 30 million
however despite the collaboration of
mick jagger and martin scorsese vinyl
landed with neither critics nor
audiences so why did it cost so much
money well much like 70s rock too much
is never enough that's what i'm talking
about the pilots episode was effectively
one big scene crammed with everything
viewers could expect from the rest of
the season in the case of vinyl this
manifested in a large ensemble cast a
sweeping wardrobe of authentic 70s garb
and a catalog of licensed music the
pilot's 30 million dollar price tag was
just 33
of the first season's 100 million dollar
budget which would ultimately sink the
show before it could take off
the big bang theory had become a massive
show by its 11th season it's 250 plus
episodes brimmed with the affectionate
geekiness that fans around the world
identified with so for the season's
final episode which featured the
marriage of amy and sheldon the show
needed an extra special guest that guest
of course was mark hamill the iconic
star wars actor
hamill was the perfect choice to
officiate the wedding of two super geeks
and he also brought some extra star
power to the show although this wedding
episode already boasted a bevy of high
profile cameos including kathy bates
jerry o'connell laurie metcalf will
wheaton plus many more and that's
basically how a simple sitcom can cost
nine million dollars for a single
episode
rome is another lavish production that
was overwhelmed by its budget in many
ways rome set the stage for game of
thrones which would reach a far bigger
audience using a similar brew of power
politics and violence the budgetary peak
for rome came with the depiction of the
battle of philippi which occurred in 42
bc during the liberators civil war it's
a huge scene that mixes dozens of extras
clad in full suits of armor and carrying
a variety of weapons also everything we
see is supplemented by cgi that
multiplies the scene scope many times
over tv had never been staged like this
before a towering blend of sword and
standard grandeur mixed with modern grit
and violence
game of thrones is a show that's too big
to mention just once of all the chaos
and majesty that we witnessed the dragon
attack in season seven's fourth episode
is perhaps the most awesome and the most
expensive the execution of this
remarkable sequence was detailed in a
short hbo documentary when director of
photography rob mclaughlin learned about
the scene he had an understandable
response oh boy that is going to be a
lot of work mclaughlin's team operated
at least four cameras sometimes seven or
eight they also use three different
tracking vehicles to capture the huge
dothraki charges which were also filmed
on cameras hoisted on industrial cranes
then there were the helicopter drones
which were supplied by a third party to
add further dynamic shots to this
complex sequence the zenith of the
episode occurs when the dragon focuses
his deadly attack on the loot train
which we see from several perspectives
the practical effects team worked
tirelessly to create a seamless line of
explosions that would not only look
authentic but also push an already epic
depiction of a dragon in battle to the
next level
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you